plus de deux millions deux cent mille
canadiens reçoivent le supplément de
revenu garanti
or près de 3% de ces gens plus de 60000
personnes n'ont pas encore rempli leur
déclaration de revenus pour 2019 et sont
un risque de perdre leurs versements du
supplément de revenu garanti le 1er
janvier à ottawa ce soir au retour jean
yves duclos le président du conseil du
trésor bonsoir monsieur duclos bonsoir
monsieur fillion bonsoir à tous de
l'unité coûte
est ce que c'est normal quotas d'aînés
n'est pas encore produit leurs
déclarations de revenus mais aussi à
quel point il est difficile pour les
aînés au cours des derniers mois ou deux
choses se sont produites beaucoup de
stress beaucoup d'isolement aussi pour
répondre plus directement à votre
question
la situation est normale mais en fait il
est meilleur que ce qu'on connaît
en temps normal puisque un nombre plus
important de l'année ont tout de même
réussi au cours des derniers mois à
fournir les renseignements dont le
gouvernement canadien besoin pour verser
les les paiements de supplément de
revenu garanti
ceci étant étant dit il ya encore près
de 15000 aînés au québec près de 60000
aux pays qui n'ont pas encore fourni
s'est d'information il est encore temps
de le faire les foules ont l'air d'ici
le 29 novembre pour éviter une dilution
des paiements en janvier prochain alors
au québec l'orne 12450 six personnes qui
pourraient voir leur prestation être
interrompu ses 1,8 pour cent déjà en
ontario 27 1609 3 0 7%
plus de dix mille en
colombie-britannique plus de soixante
trois mille au canada 2,9 pour ça si ces
gens-là n'envoient pas leurs
déclarations de revenus avant le 29
novembre il se passe quoi bein l'été
n'en seraient normalement suspendu en
janvier pour ça qu'il faut absolument
faire les déclarations de revenus avec
l'agent de revenus ou encore appelé
service canada avec un numéro que vous
avez je crois qu'il est en 802 7 7 9 9 1
ce numéro est important parce que ça
permet aux aînés de fournir rapidement
par téléphone l'information sur leurs
revenus
c'est tout ce qu'il faut pour service
canada pour s'assurer que les paiements
ne soit pas suspendu
reçue du cloud redonner du numéro de
téléphone il est à l'écran merci 1 800
de 7,7 99.5 parfait vous alliez ajouté
lionnel luca et redit effectivement est
très bien organisé vous aviez déjà le
numéro
oui ce numéro qui est très important
aussi pour les aînés parce que c'est une
prestation qui pour un aîné sur 3
représente une grande part de l'aide
qu'ils reçoivent du gouvernement a
annoncé que la portabilité
particulièrement 160 p pandémie est
difficile pour beaucoup de nos aînés
donc ils ont besoin ils méritent de
recevoir cette prestation mais j'étais
mort et 9 9 ans
si encore si encore soixante mille
personnes puis dans le passé les autres
années il y avait 60 cents mille
personnes qui est ce qu'on devrait pas
rendre sa plus simple
automatiser la déclaration de revenus de
bien des gens kiprop qui qui oublient ou
qui ont conquis on peut avoir de la
difficulté à faire cette déclaration de
revenus une très bonne question et 2
chose de rapide à prendre le dessus la
première c'est que depuis décembre 2018
le versement de ce supplément de 1,6 et
automatisée pour à peu près 10 nuls est
né par mois qui atteint l'âge de 65 ans
et une recommandation que la fadoq nous
avait fait c'était une excellente
formation c'est en place depuis donc un
peu plus de deux heures la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on veut avec l'agencé de
revenu du canada
comme vous l'avez dit automatiser le
plus possible les déclarations de
revenus parce qu'ils y avant celle des
années qui peaufine en plusieurs cas
sont assez simples à remplir mais pour
des raisons d'isolement parfois des
raisons de connexion par internet
on a difficultés à fournir leur revenu
est pas encore encore plus cette année
vous parlez d'isolement il ya beaucoup
des knicks sont isolés je répète pas
question s'il ya des gens qui sont pas
capables de le faire avant le 29
novembre mais ce que vous aller couper
supplément de revenu garanti au 1er
janvier pour ces gens là on va tout
faire pour éviter de couper les
prestations parce qu'elles sont
essentielles pour les aînés il faut que
les aînés fourni ces informations un
moment donné entre autres parce qu'il
faut que les bons montant soit versée
aux aînés en janvier dans certains cas
les montants vont être augmentés en
fonction des revenus
nouveau que des années vont communiquer
dans certains cas ils vont être
légèrement réduit aujourd'hui on veut
éviter que ses aînés soient obligés de
rembourser les versements excédentaires
autre point monsieur monsieur ministre
les gens qui ont reçu de l'apc ou qui
prennent la prestation canadienne de
relance économique en ce moment qui
touche généralement le supplément de
revenu garanti
ça va venir affecte ça va venir vous
faire baisser leur supplément de revenu
garanti en 2021 n'est ce pas ben
effectivement tout dépendant des
conditions individuel ça départ des
montants que les aînés ont reçu ça
dépend aussi des circonstances
particulières en cours pour une personne
seule donc beaucoup de choses là qui
sont tenus en compte par l' agence
devenu du canada met à nouveau les aînés
ont besoin d'être traités avec respect
et de recevoir l'information dont ils
ont de loin ils n'ont ils doivent pas
hésiter contacter service canada où
l'agent de revenus ciel quoi quelques
doutes que ce soit qui existe dans leur
esprit mais il y aura pas ce que je veux
dire c'est compte tenu de l'année
incroyable que nous connaissons il n'y
aura pas d'exception l'an prochain si
vous avez un revenu plus élevé imposable
ça va venir affecter votre accès à au
supplément de revenu garanti aura pas de
changement là dessus non mais la pcu est
une prestation imposables comme
l'assurance emploi il est aussi une
récession imposable donc ça rentre dans
le calcul du revenu imposable
il arrive de s'applique pour tous les
autres types de revenus imposables ou
six ok donc je rappelle et je termine là
dessus 1 800 de 7,7 9,9 1,5 pour les
gens pour les soixante trois mille
canadiens qui pourraient perdre leurs
prestations du supplément de revenu
garanti merci monsieur duclos merci à
vous recevoir et